guys before the video starts i'm doing a
winter appeal for syria afghanistan and
ethiopia province sisters inshallah
people are literally freezing we will
never live in those conditions help me
reach my target to give them some walk
i've done the seven day free trial of
the korani app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses not credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated download it and see what time
it is
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are willing inshallah
before i start one place allah the most
merciful the most just or praise his
glory and gratitude belong to him in
this video that i came across this was
in america it's
a youtube channel called jubilee and in
that video you have a group of muslims
who are standing and they asked a
question and they've got some white
lines on the floor and they have
questions of how strongly you disagree
to agree
mediocre whatever it may be yeah so here
we go this is let's see what the
question is and let's see how they react
to it and see what we can learn from
this
i have okay so we can see on the floor
strongly disagree disagree somewhat
disagree somewhat agree agree and
strongly agree so
if you notice i'm sure you've noticed
none of them is on the side of agree or
strongly agree
most of them a bit more on this side you
know you've got one sister who strongly
disagrees you've got another sister who
disagrees you've got one brother
somewhat disagrees no one's really in
the middle of a hamdulillah at least
we've got three that's on the somewhat
agree side which is understandable but
let's delve into this a bit more strong
feelings
i just feel like it's okay
one just changes the whole mind okay a
woman's right to cover if she wants to
and to tell a woman what to do with her
body is totally against our islamic
principles so you know hold on a second
let's pause this for a second uh to tell
a woman to cover her body is against his
time principles no it's not this is an
absolute lie
let's be honest you know seriously let's
stop sugarcoating our religion yeah
because what it does it backfires on us
and the thing is this whole concept of
covering oneself
why is it seen as a religious obligation
like judaism christianity islam um in
other religions let's say sikhism hindus
and whatever it may be they have some
some sort of covering
as well
why is it that religions and
specifically islam that we are the only
ones that somehow um not force but are
told yeah now i'm going to delve into
that a bit more with my favorite book
beauty sake because it dismantles this
completely but let's just carry on
hey guy here i just i just made a really
conscious decision to be like somewhat
agree because people don't understand
that hijab is like a concept as far as
like it's not just like the actual head
scarf islam really promotes the idea of
modesty and that's how you get closer to
god and if you feel like having a head
scarf is a way for you to get closer to
god then so be it
headscarf is not just hijab let's just
get that right okay 100 agree with that
because it's not just a head scarf it's
your behavior it's a personality it's
how you treat your friends and your
neighbors yeah for a lot of people the
processes build my courage my bravery
and my confidence and then wear the
scarf for me it was kind of reverse i
started with the scarf because i knew
that i was not going to build that
bravery unless i started wearing it
because when you put it on you start
acting different you start acting nicer
you're kinder because now you're
representing your religion your faith
let's break this down now the question i
want to ask is very simple
does somebody
willingly starve their self
does somebody willingly feel ugly
does somebody feel
willingly so ugly that she believes that
she is worthless and she willingly has
sex with men yes intimacy sexual
intercourse with men does someone
willingly cut an apple into eight slices
and have it every two hours an hour an
hour so they don't feel hungry so they
can have the ideal body does somebody
wake up willingly and spend two hours
putting on makeup does somebody
willingly don't want to go out because
they feel ugly does someone willingly
spend thousands of pounds
on their looks does someone willingly go
and get literally amputate in in a sense
you know get their nose smashed because
they won't have the perfect nose or get
their lips done or get the buttocks done
and some people actually die in the
process they actually die in the process
i want to ask a simple question do these
individuals these girls which is a
pandemic
a pandemic in the book that i read the
author says it's a pandemic
how
millions of girls around the world may
be in their billions feel insecure feel
ugly feel so unattractive that one of
the authors the author says in a book
that a girl who she was interviewing
said i felt so ugly that i felt so
worthless that i thought no man wants to
be with me so i would go and sleep
around and she says that if i had time
if i could turn about time turn back
time that she would never done that
this for some reason is not forced so
let me get this right as muslims we are
forced and you know everyone's going to
disagree etc it's a woman's choice no no
no no let me see let me make it very
clear it's not my choice to wake up in
for fajr in the morning no i am told to
do it i am told not i choose to i do not
choose to grow a beard i am told to grow
a beard i am told to fast i am told to
pray i am told to give him zakah i am
told to be good and i'm told to stay
away from major sins let's get away from
this liberal
notion that no no we have the choice no
you don't have the choice i don't have
the choice it's not just you
and neither do these girls who do not
wear the hijab who you know the western
woman yeah
who do not have the choice either so
where do we both meet because we both
don't have choices the point is the
following and i will wrap up with this
and i get anyone to come and debate me
on this topic
very clearly
everybody is bound to be forced like one
philosopher said every man is born free
but is in shackles everywhere meaning
either you're going to be forced by your
society and be a slave to your society
yeah and the beauty industry and what's
the beauty beauty ideal which the offer
and the beauty success that is actually
rigged you can never reach that yet you
can never reach that
or you obey the one that created you
it's as simple as that both of them are
telling you to do something one doesn't
deserve to be worshipped one doesn't
deserve for you to be enslaved to the
other one deserves to be worshipped
because he created you and deserves your
enslavement i'm not doing about
enslavement not you know like a you know
get whipped and be up no
with the promise of paradise and his
worth
and his worthy of worship and once you
enslave yourself to him you only have to
prove your point to him and he doesn't
look at your beauty or your outer
appearance he does not care how you look
he only cares about what's inside you
taqwa
taqwa taqwa
and that is the most beautiful thing and
that is the reason why so many women are
flocking to islam because they free
themselves and they take control of
their sexuality and they do not be eye
candy for men who use and abuse them
that makes me sick to come across woman
in the dm people message me telling me i
was in a relationship and i got dumped
yeah i got broken up why
because you have no security these men
young men are polygamous men who want to
gain a relationship with you get what
they want because you've given them
everything they want nothing to save no
security nothing to hold on to they
leave and go and you think it was a
relationship they didn't work no this
was a man who was practicing polygamy
because men are polygamous by nature
practicing polygamy you happen to be one
of those girls he got what he was and
now he's moving on to another mate
because he's polygamous and he's going
to do the same with the next girl and
the next girl and the next girl until he
decides to settle down
that is my point here and i'll end on
that note inshallah so let's not come
with this oh you know we choose to not
you do not you either choose to obey
allah or you choose to obey the creation
you choose
till next time don't ever come to me or
anybody come and tell me women are
oppressed alhamdulillah for islam till
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh